we're going to the arts district now
where a mural there has been restored so
the mural which there's a lot of them
down there but this one in particular
was painted white by an ad agency people
complained and now it's back mary jane
belly is alive this morning in the arts
district with what local businesses are
seeing mary jean good morning
john and heather good morning to you i
mean beautiful murals like this one it's
more than just art it's a wonderful form
of expression and really contributes to
the culture of the arts district art
advocate and board member becky miller
says the mural was painted over in white
by an ad agency and it's now restored
after receiving much support from the
community it's located across nevada
brew works and the unique mural really
sprawls across the wall behind jammin in
vegas
local businesses in the arts district
say this incident goes a long way in
supporting our artists and each other
and i think that you know the city and
the 18b board
has always taken active roles and i'm
sure they'll continue to take more
active roles as well
and
making sure that the artists are
considered because if you lose your
heart and soul you're going to lose a
lot i mean it's sad that it even had to
happen in the beginning but in the first
place but it just it's you know i guess
you can't get to look at it from a
positive standpoint that they were at
least willing to
bring it back to the community
now miller says the building where the
mural is located on will also be
renovated and you can kind of see here
as we get a closer look some of that
white paint that was painted over that
mural luckily it was pretty easy to wash
off here and you can see just absolutely
how beautiful and gorgeous it is and you
can come out here and check it out it's
located on main street and imperial
avenue reporting live from the arts
district mary jane balliesa live local
now